you mentioned your
dad he passed away uh two
a year and a half ago yeah what did you
learn from him
i love my dad my dad i would say my dad
was my
my hero he was just uh my dad really
embodied those values and i think um
for better or worse it's made me who i
am he's he uh my dad
was a painter he was a lawyer he was uh
he was a
you know a lieutenant in the military
new yorker
new yorker born and bred brooklyn his
doubt his dad you know uh surprise owned
a diner so that's
that's sort of the greek passport that's
the immigration passport for greeks into
america
and um yeah my dad played football he
just my dad did what he wanted he lived
as he wanted at all costs and i think i
got that from him where for better or
worse i think it's hurt me
in my pursuits uh if if you consider
money and fame uh to be paramount
you know i i've always done what i
wanted if i stopped wanting to do it i
just stopped doing it i think i got that
from my dad so maybe
for better or worse that's what i
learned from him but that's a real
currency you know
feeling like you're in love with what
you're doing when you're doing it
maybe perhaps that's worth more than
money i don't know
you miss him yeah every day every day
but i'm happy that uh
he he got 91 years it's very rare
i mean he smoked for 60 years talk about
like a guy who was an outlier and he
smoked like six years like
packs i mean yeah and he didn't die from
that he died he had a
prostate cancer which is the way men
should go your dick should give out
it should start from the dick i mean we
focus so much of our life on the dick
that that's the way that's a successful
life and that's why every man eventually
gets prostate cancer because that is the
universe's way of saying like
the thing you focused on the most is you
put the most energy into is the thing
that's spent
and it's gonna your your rotting is
gonna start there so that's a successful
life
and it just spread all over his body and
he slowly died i was with him when he
died and that meant a lot to me
because me and my brother weren't
talking at the time because we're greeks
uh
we're we're talking again but that's how
it is you got a few brothers right
i got two brothers but i wanted to make
sure i was with him uh
when he died and i got lucky and i was
in the room with him when he died
you were in the room with your brother
and you weren't no my brother wasn't
there we were kind of doing shifts i was
i was there i spent the night the dad my
the night my dad died he died in the
early in the morning and i heard
the death rattle last breath and it was
just i think it was
uh i he knew i was there and uh i think
that just
probably meant something to him and i'm
just glad i was there
does that make you sad that uh life is
ephemeral like you said
yeah that that you die yeah what do you
think about your own death
you meditate on that i think it i think
the actual
if there is a point to life it's to um
hopefully not fear death to accept
reality i think that's important i think
so much goes awry in the human condition
when we
lose touch with reality every uh
political system that's led to mass
murder and everything i think
because it's because the
the tenets of those political
philosophies
ended up being utopian they were
detached from reality
detached from nature and so i think it's
it's very important to
accept and acknowledge your own
mortality i think it's the foundation
for what makes a good person a moral
person
um a contributing member of society
because it's true
true things should be the foundation of
all things
if if if what you believe is based on
illusion you're gonna end up doing
destruction
whether that destruction is on a scale
of one to ten you are going to be
destructive because it's not
real it's a fantasy it doesn't exist see
the thing is the
truth is about i don't think you can
ever reach truth truth is about like
constantly digging and to push back in
your idea that you should accept death
i think the more honest response to
death so the least
honest is to run away from it create
illusions
that help you imagine that there's not a
death
the next is to accept it but the real
honest one is to fear it
because i i i mean i'm i'm with
ernest becker as a philosopher uh wrote
a book called denial of death
he says that the like much of the human
condition is based in the fear of
mortality
that we like that's that's the creative
force of the human energy like freud
said you want to sleep with your mother
he said no that's not what motivates you
maybe his mom wasn't hot though
i mean or he wasn't greek because
apparently edible we we found we found
that all things good
and bad yeah you thanks thanks for that
thanks
i just don't know if his mom was look or
not i mean i'd have to google it all
right
yeah i'll look up on google images
yeah no but i think that honest as he
says
the thing that we run away from is that
there's a terror he calls it like
terror there's something called terror
management theory that's
some philosophers after him followed on
that were basically trying to run away
from this fear
and acceptance is actually creating an
illusion for yourself
like you can actually accept something
as terrifying as this
so he's more with the stoics the stoic
constantly meditate on their death i
mean they
what does that mean that means kind of
it's
you know acceptance of death isn't a
thing you do like
on a monday and then you're done it's a
thing you constantly
have to meditate on like reminding
yourself
like this ride is over it could be over
today and that's something you're
if you think about every single day it
gives you an appreciation of woody allen
movies
at least it gives the appreciation
basically everything
including woody allen movies which shows
you how deep your appreciation for life
could be
i've actually haven't been following
much about what woody allen's
but apparently he's been a troublemaker
for most of his life
he's yeah i mean you know he's caused a
little bit of strife he's left a little
uh yeah he's left a little confusion in
his wake
for sure but i mean you know
that's another one separate the art from
the artist he's got
i mean the guys will go down in history
as the greatest he's made i mean a movie
a year
and they're all you can always find
something good about each movie like the
dialogue or whatever
um i love what you're saying it's
interesting but the only thing i would
say to push back a little bit since
we're playing a little table tennis here
yeah
is um i don't know if it's a choice to
fear death that's more of an
it seems more instinctual it seems like
something that
nature wants you to do because i've been
in positions where i thought i was gonna
die like i've been shot and
i had those moments and then nature also
uh you know kicks in an instinct which
is acceptance
where you kind of i don't know it's a
chemical release or whatever i don't
know
you know we're all we're robots
basically so some sort of chemical is
released that protects you but
there is an acceptance i don't know how
much uh
of was a conscious choice probably very
little um
and that's the point i'm making is it's
instinctual we don't really have a
choice
in fearing death otherwise there would
be no progression we wouldn't
all life seems to want to survive
uh not by choice but by instinct
so he he argues that the fear is not the
instinctual
it's not the animalistic stuff that's
the thing that makes us special
is the what humans are able to do is
they have a knowledge that we're going
to die one day animals don't have that
animals fear is instinctual it's like
holy [ __ ] what's that sound over there
he says we're actually able to
contemplate the fact that this ride ends
and that that kind of cognitive
construct
is difficult for us to deal with like
what the hell does that mean
like just just to think about
it's going to be over at a certain point
it's just over lights out like it's very
difficult to kind of load that into
whatever this like little brain we got
like what does that actually mean
you